[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen welcome to
comedy film nerds episode 354 lot to
talk about though I'm amazing Academy
Award nominations we got to be speaking
about also we're going to be talking
about trespass against us Lion the
founder Jackie lotta big action-packed
show today well we've got cut out all
right we've got done sequence there's a
car chase in this episode you're going
to love it it's getting a twist ending
to show or will it yeah we don't know
who one of us maybe is the criminal yeah
I don't know where to go after that this
isn't really good improv we have a good
enough we have a big la casa now for
gaming on februari 15th we're making the
big announcement d dates everything boom
big announcement that can already has
made your fears that we're not doing it
again yeah we're doing it again it'll be
in the fall again mmm in 10 got an
announcement that was like the Vegas I
know we're announcing that we're going
to have an announcement we're gonna over
over hyping the hyping and weirdoes
there be an announcement about a venue
change where has the Ponce s been the
last three years it was at the sofitel
in Beverly Hills and then two years
prior to that was in Santa mamma need a
sudoku it went three days it's always
friday saturday sunday so it'll be it'll
be friday saturday so non-stop podcast
nah how many do you guys do during that
see i'm plugging you I like having your
own
haha you guys be there every day yeah
we're there every day we well we do a
comedy film ER is live and then we're
usually guests on a couple of shows
there's a big stand up on saturday night
we do the whole stand-up show so panels
panels we would love to have you there
okay I'll be there I'll give you the
dates well in February 15 yes perfect
yes and like if you're around because I
know you're not doing your podcast
anymore by the way this is our guest
Mary Lynn Rajskub have we said her name
is a really write something for having
me it's been like a few years a while
yeah yeah great to have you back weird
guide yeah I think you're like 24 is
still on the air right or people were
still bugging you when the next one was
going to be on the air yeah but
happening again because there it never
really goes away but they're re-airing
old episodes and they're launching the
new one after the Star Wars so now
people are like I'm i meant yeah it's
not not complaining but people are like
oh no are you watching season five are
you in the new series with the new lead
absolutely not okay but you will get
residual checks when they rear any old
ones hey no it's not that great oh yeah
[ __ ] that's a different kind of residual
cuz there's an alternative residual is
no friends ridiculous it's like oh I
just can't go buy groceries no all right
once a year we just need to eat that
often oh god believe me I'm well off
when I go to ralphs I just buy whatever
oh [ __ ] yeah it's so kind of like that
Ralph private select you can privates
leg bacon friendly no one here Ralph
goes into his special way you got to be
part of the club is the private sweat
yeah this is this deal's off brand cola
private selected cycle blows the dust
off of it Ralph bring to the hub time
there is dust on them
Shh all right look high that started
yeah let's do it do it but I think
that's a greater we should definitely
invite Marilyn to La Paz fest this year
even if you're even if you're not doing
your podcast as a guest or doing
stand-up on the standard l don't stand
up guys oh I know here's the news Kevin
I'm shadow were there yeah every time I
talk to you you pump me up about do it
yourself yes I'm still clinging on to
but but it's gotta go in a way for look
if I we all the old school system if I
was still getting checks from the old
school system I would be holding on what
area you know like I'm not they just
topped hiring me so I was sort of forced
into this garage but like that's one of
the reason this is a refugee camp of
sources of the cuddliest refugee
intimate who's known boom meow meow meow
i'ma leave your house that's why this is
in my garage yeah yeah I have to drive
ya little my favorite I want to be on
here morn let me just go see more movies
which would be great I start doing that
while my kids in school and I Drive here
because it's close to my house hey I'm a
deeper in the valley am the parent movie
viewing time is friday 11 when they're
already at school it's always just me
and a bunch of other old people wander
into the wrong film fantastic yeah can
you walk two films no no I go to the
galleria not sweet but let's talk about
I want to talk about this movie trespass
against us is the first movie I saw over
the week I don't know anything about
this now I was excited about this movie
this one is Brendan Gleeson and Michael
Fassbender it was their kind of like it
felt like a winter's bone kind of like
almost like hillbilly criminals in the
UK you know they live in the trailer
park yeah yeah this movie was not that
good oh then at a couple of hrs larger
yeah yeah and this is one of those
things where it had a very large logic
flaw that kind of was bothering me
throughout the entire film now the
biggest problem with this film is that
these are like small-time criminals who
live in a trailer park you know they you
know they
piss off the police and they do you know
occasional criminal jobs and apparently
Michael Fassbender is a master race car
driver who can always out outfox the
police in a car they do a big job and
apparently they break into this house
that you know it's got millions of
dollars in the hall so I'm thinking if
these guys are such master criminals why
are they living in a trailer park why
are they in a hovel because or if
they're not such master criminals why
can't the police catch them or pin
anything on them like well I've never
been charged you know all this is like
well what's on herself so yeah it accent
yeah hey I've never been charged oh my
god any of y'all off I'll mentioned crab
I believe I'm getting the vapors it's a
wall here in the UK yeah so it's ass
weird movie that really just doesn't
make a lot of sense but one of the
things that I will say is that Brendan
Gleeson and Michael Fassbender their
performances are so good it like
elevates the Madonna like it's worth
watching just for their performances
like they really do the best with you
know what they have to work with the
other thing too it was it felt like a
little bit like attack the block where
the dialect is so thick and so having
even when you can occasionally
understand the word and like I'm not
really sure what that means because it's
slang its UK slang so I had trouble
following a couple of seems like i'm not
sure what they're talking about so that
I in your head you just change it to
southern so you could understand as we
like it well kiss my grits yeah yes I
look really perfect sense to me so I
know that's why so but it's like has
these weird things like okay so easy
there master criminals but they live in
the trailer park but their kids yet
still they go to school so they have a
school thing co2 and they get dropped
off to school and it was it was all
these weird things kind of put together
I'm like I don't know how much this was
thought through like if you look at a
movie like winters bone where that whole
world was created with Jennifer mines
and you know these kind of hillbilly
criminals or whatever but there was
never like you know like that Dukes of
Hazzard scene where like the state
troopers were chasing him in the car I
just can't catch him you know it but
that as this movie has those scenes so
it's like it kind of been really fit
yeah okay so this is an English is a
bigot hazard go to a rural language ok L
speakin and I didn't eligible try this
one so there was life is deeply getting
a GD today's me yeah that's kind of what
it sounded like you'll never get me
lucky charms okay that says a lot to be
good in the film that sounds as bad as
you're describing yeah you know yes so
it was there there were some definitely
the brightest parts were the acting for
sure guy like and maybe you know
brindle's you guys are great actors so
good and together like as a father and
son by the way they also play a father
and son in assassin's creed that no one
saw wow so it's you know you're Adam
Smith's first feature film we do the TV
director and Alistair students sit don't
sit done first screenplay so you know
I'd be anxious to see what their next
project would be together but this one
was kind of like if so we gonna miss
what is this sort of been the theme and
we'll get into some other movie yet
obviously that are you know the Oscar
nominations came out today but like and
then sort of been the theme of this year
is like there hasn't been that many
super solid movies there's been good
performances yeah it's weird it's like a
lot of these movies is like where you
can find a couple really good solid
things in them but overall they're not
great so huh so we've definitely seeing
a lot so kind of a week Oscar year this
year yeah sure except on the animation
Department it's so racist of you to say
but I heard about trespass against us i
heard that Dev Patel was really hot you
heard a wreck systems EG i know wow i
heard its package get great wow you guys
had your march and now you're just going
out sexualize that's what we did it
we're going to talk about municipal dude
like shitty coming out of my mouth yeah
I don't care if I had more problems with
the acts of voice you or your character
that did this absolutely out of level I
know my wife so could you please step
off equality well you want some sweet Oh
God Oh are we back in Scotland for backe
reckon Scotland where by the way it says
it's an irish american film yeah all
right kind of participate guy thank you
well let's you're welcome okay so let's
talk about you you saw the movie Jackie
which all right include me yeah yeah I
don't all this movie when i first
started watching it i was in the first
minute or two I thought this is going to
be my favorite movie really I loved it i
thought it looked different and to see
her i said because at first you know
like why would i want to watch a movie
about Jackie and then when it started I
thought oh cuz you see her anger and
right away it opens with the journalist
at the doorway and they're into it and
she's defensive and she's loyal and
she's angry and he's combative with her
and then you know they're going to start
doing flashbacks and then it's this
antagonistic interview with Billy Crudup
and her and I thought now you're talking
and that you know music is kind of odd
and creepy a exemplifying her let you
know the heart-wrenching right guys got
these weird off tone string section type
now that you love it all the way through
no and then within the first I was
really with it for like probably 15-20
minutes and then I realized that I was
being slowly assassinated my spirit 0010
a bad screenwriter was on the grassy
knoll and took off to the dialogue what
like what was the part of it that was
killing you it never
went anywhere and for the setup of
showing all these colors of her and this
behind the scenes like you know she's
telling him yes of course you can't
print that she's smoking through the
whole thing saying yeah I don't smoke
and so you think oh this is cool because
i'm getting the juicy backstory and i'm
getting the story of this woman of like
what's really going on and sort of kind
of a it's brave to just take it you know
from when he dies and like we're just
gonna watch what happens and i'm like i
am down for this story right to the
right cool the majority of her adult
life has been your husband was killed
like that's her whole identity and what
a cool idea to sort of delve into that
well it never goes anywhere it builds at
the beginning and then it just plateaus
and the whole movie is just her deciding
to have this elaborate procession for
him and then they advised her not to and
it's sort of how she wants everything to
be beautiful and how she's sort of a
victim now because I mean she's a very
strong opinionated woman but the whole
tone of the movie is just okay my
husband died and now no one can
understand me and all the shots are like
just her alone which at first is so
interesting because you're like we're
going to get into her head but it never
goes anywhere no one ever changes the
the thing that it keeps going back to is
the interview he just ends up leaving
like well okay i guess i'm going to
write what you tell me to write I'm
bye-bye and it never willed into
anything and then it just sort of ends
in the same place where it started but
it's this really sensitive it's almost
like a just a one-note character story
the whole thing and it's frustrating
because for all the effort and the
beauty of like recreating those scenes
and going through the trouble to make it
all period and make it really cool
looking which is the one Oscar
nomination it got with costume design
right it didn't look like the the
approach of doing the flashbacks and
stuff which could have been really
useful just ended up having it be the
same throughout who's very bizarre
because I kept waiting for it to take
off
you wanted her performance was good but
her character her performance is great
but after a while she's just in the same
space and yes it's an emotional
conflicted angry it's an awesome space
but you put in onenote 100 yeah i mean
her performance is not one note but it's
but the movie listen yeah the movie is
right okay Wow because she's up for Best
Actress yeah Natalie Portman yeah I mean
she does a great job it's just
frustrating how the story never goes
anywhere yeah so that's that's a shame
because it really feels like this was
like an opportunity to really show
something interesting about ya know not
just sort of like a untold story of
something that everyone knows overly
well what was it also was length the
problem was like since it didn't really
go anywhere we did it feel just too long
I I kept having this where I'm hanging
in there it is it is rich and her
performance is layered and so you're
like oh now something's gonna turn out
her accent bizarre yeah it's okay it's
not it didn't take me out of the movie
it's real breathy but I did go back and
watch a clip of the real thing and I
thought oh she did her version of it
it's not really I mean I think that's
the chem really tricky to do the Kennedy
one is that you don't because it can be
so sketch cartoonish so quickly just wow
you know if I yeah as I doesn't do that
to her credit she does go really breathy
and it's it's another running things
throughout the film which I didn't
remember was she does a famous tour of
the White House that was on TV so they
make the footage look really far away
and then and grainy and she's just kind
of presenting and now this is where we
had the Shakespeare play and I just want
everything to be beautiful here in the
White House so it shows you what she did
you know to make it that the the myth of
Camelot and there's some great ideas in
it like you know life is the story that
you tell and the rent is going to live
and she was very concerned with his
legacy and there's really cool
conversations with what she would she
would have with the priest which again
she's almost antagonistic with everybody
and playing the victim and then she got
into some conversations about God and
why does God hate me and why would God
do this to me and well according to our
notes to this is a very American story
directed by and I University not a lot
of jajajaja endure Ector Pablo Lorraine
it's his first American film although
still shot mostly in Paris oh and
originally set to star Rachel whites and
directed by darren aronofsky and I'll
say oh yeah yeah and the one other thing
I was frustrating about it is that it
was so in her point of view which I
loved that idea but then by the end I
was longing for some more somebody a
politics and so are yours what the world
thinks because it's so much from her
point of view that it sort of exhausted
that so you could have used some like
here's her talking to LBJ or Bobby
Kennedy and everybody Alex wood outside
of her he never got what was really
going on with LBJ they were from her
point of view oh they're taking over now
you know and I see them picking out the
new colors for the itõs of the furniture
ah wow you know that's what's creating
yeah I guess that's why so I got those
two nominations she got better at Best
Actress nomination and Captain design
which sounds like those are the two
highlights of the moment all right let's
talk about a movie that you really well
let's talk about okay I'm all right well
what do you want you I was gonna do you
want you to finally we do the founder
word line let's do founder since we both
saw that absolutely okay the founder was
a movie I really wanted to see I had
actually read fast food nation which
delves a little bit into this story
between the mcdonalds brothers and Ray
Kroc who Roy Crocker eight o'clock ray
mr. crock yeah great cross right here a
crock and I really wanted to see what
Michael Keaton was going to bring to
what I was curious to see like
especially there's some very funny
people in this movie and to see if there
would be like kind of like a
God yeah and you know kind of a sense of
humor to this film there is not humorous
film at all it is played completely
straight there's no irony to it there's
literally it's what you're doing is
you're watching a movie that feels like
cliffs notes of the book it's pretty
much what what you feel like you're
watching and here's why Michael Keaton
basically plays a con artist you know
he's a low-level con artist he's trying
to sell stuff sales of sales but even
see how he starts to go but really I'll
sat in the heart of the car magazine
know what you're saying is a and what
you're watching in the film is his slow
rise to success at the expense of pretty
much everyone else mm-hmm and when you
have a movie like that and I was
thinking about like why is this movie
reasoning why isn't there something
about this movie that's just off that
makes me not interested in watching this
and the reason is to when you have a
movie that has one destination to get to
a predestined point we know what happens
we know what's going to get there so you
can't have an interesting movie when
it's a slow deterioration to a pre Deb
predetermined point so all you're doing
is watching Michael Keaton's characters
slowly fleece these guys until he
becomes successful and then that's
pretty much that you want to say because
you didn't like him yes well out of it
well that what happens is he's set up a
little bit of like Ollie's a guy who's
down on his luck he's a Salesman but you
know as the movie progresses he pretty
much turns into almost like a sociopath
has he Rob's these guys of their
business and you know his marriage to
your rates and by the way larger and is
literally nothing to do except for make
disapproving faces header tonight
there's literally that's all she has
gonna do yeah so I got divorced yes okay
think about it a little bit and I was
like where did it go wrong and what and
I realized it's focused on the wrong
story the real story is the McDonald's
brothers and what they built and how
they slowly lost everything too
a charlatan and a con artist because it
sets up this really dopey contrivance at
the beginning when Ray Kroc meets them
things like I got to take you to dinner
I want to know your story and like oh ok
so and then that's when they start
telling the story at dinner and we do
flashbacks and stuff but I'm looking at
this story and this is far more
interesting than watching a guy steal a
business for two hours because they do
stuff like they you know they start a
stand and successful and then they have
to move it and they won't fit under an
underpass oh they're sawing it in half
and moving it that way it's so
interesting to see their rise and fall
and ultimately fall like that's the
story that would have been far a far
more interesting and compelling film and
you have Ray Kroc is essentially the
villain that ultimately wins at the end
you have this up-and-down roller coaster
to see their successes in failure other
than just a slow steady decline well
that's interesting I think I liked it a
little more than you did I wasn't like
blown away by it it is very a little bit
by the numbers historical movie john lee
hancock as the director he did saving
mr. banks the blind side the alamo the
rookie so he's literally done almost all
of you know true stories i guess to me I
liked it a little more maybe just
because I like this sort of Michael
Keaton resurgence you know spotlight
Birdman send those movies he had a lot
more to do a lot more interesting things
to do with the character yeah I think
he's really mad at your English fighting
by geladen my Giza math no years oh yeah
yeah and I go see this is how we fight
yeah yeah Michael Keaton manager get
very mad at Chris I don't know I guess I
just like watching these two weaklings
lose a fight I guess it was sort of
interesting like I I agree when they did
tell that story and that was a really
interesting part of the movie because
they showed actual black and white [ __ ]
like photos of the of the actual
original McDonald's in San Bernardino
and how they figured out the assembly
line way of doing fast food we were all
amazing it was all really cool but um it
was interesting I I felt like Michael
Keaton had a little bit more of an arc
in the sense that he did start out as
this guy who's trying to sell milk
shakes machines and he's like oh don't
in mind it being about him and that
story no I didn't I didn't I think I
think was that was interesting enough to
me just because I knew a little bit
about Ray Kroc I heard you know the
famous speech he gave I can't remember
what it was like the harvard business
school or something as all these young
business kids and he was like what
business in a man they're all like Oh
hamburgers food money goes no real
estate and so I knew that was sort of
his story of how he built that Empire
was he bought the real estate under
under the franchise's and I was like oh
and so seeing how he got to that place
and how the mcdonalds brothers kind of
he was like he asked for a raise and a
better deal and they're like no mountain
open there too they won't let go of
their baby in essence and how he had to
get past that and the flaws of kind of
who he was so i found it a little more
interesting hmm and maybe I just I just
really like Michael Keaton you don't
think that all salesmen are charlatans
like Chris uh well Chris hate America he
hate my capital is oh no he's got a
better get with the program yeah he's a
socialist things are different look at
me New York at all right you guys all
right brother recording this right right
again I'll move to Canada you can go up
there with the rest of your God yeah
free healthcare hippie buddy um no I
just thought it was interesting and that
sort of old style of business of just
like beats a competitor you know like
cocktails and and crush him you know so
yeah robert siegel screenwriter for the
onion movie and the wrestler wrote this
movie no no I think I did it okay that I
was not funny not funny and it was what
I would have liked to have seen and I
was looking into notes to the Coen
brothers one
to direct it but we're tied up with Hail
Caesar I would have loved was seen the
Coen brothers directive soon I agree i
think they could have done a far better
job um this guy did some interesting
stuff and i think it's mainly it's to me
if you do enjoy this movie it's the
strength of Keaton is what you're going
to enjoy I guess but you know it's not
surprising to me too that this movie
really didn't get any nominations at all
no it wasn't on any level it was just
another sort of film that that now I
would drop that did again like you see
the trailer for this and you go Oscar
boy here we go like Keaton true story
you know American icon go now and yeah
yeah and then it didn't hit those things
at all now I will ask you this though I
know you're vegetarian but at the
beginning when what does that have to do
with anything yeah when Ray Kroc was
like visiting McDonald's for the first
time you saw the energy and like the
newness of just like this big fancy
restaurant everybody did it kind of one
you make you eat a cheeseburger it made
me want to go to veggie grill yeah
that's fast food vegetarian place has
popped up and so there's never been
Great minute ryzza thankfully good so
good yeah like at the beginning I was
like I just kind of want a cheeseburger
and then towards the end of moving like
I don't know whatever good woman yeah I
mean yeah and it to me I guess it also
brought up the childhood and I think
every American kid has some sort of
mcdonald oh absolutely oh yeah dori or
and I just share my brother-in-law
worked at McDonald's three years my
brother worked at McDonald's in high
school and he would come home smelling
like burgers he was a burger guy hmm I
remember when they came up with Sunday's
for the first time and it was buy one
get one free and my brother and I were
fighting over who got the free one and
who got the page that's the doorman and
I like through the mcdonalds is depicted
in its own were built from scratch for
the film because with the you know the
way the old arches went and I remember
if you remember on Highland Avenue I
think it either sunset or Hollywood they
used to have that Burger man yeah there
i think it's gone now today that was
like the last old style yeah you know me
yeah alright so let's not since oh well
I want to go into this next movie
because we've been talking a lot about
there has been no real strong Oscar
movie right here like there has been no
like 12 years a slave or spotlight no
break out some movie that you walked out
and went Wow start to finish like I
remember watching spotlight I was
riveted from starts to start to finish
yeah 12 years a slave I remember just
being like Jesus that movie was so good
every aspect of it was great you weren't
checking your watch you weren't checking
for watch and a lot of the movies we've
talked about thus far as in this Oscar
race you know uh fences good
performances a little too you know that
me like hidden figures had good parts of
it but nothing that was like so knocked
me out the whole time until last night I
saw a lion okay now fellas about four
people have done that with this movies
about teller give us an a a little of
summer um so it's about it's a true
story about a kid that was all this is
the dev patel room yeah this is a dead
patel movie it's about a young kid in
india who they're poor and you know so
he's got an older brother who's like
1200 s they there he has to work heat
the kids like five the mom picks up
rocks that's her job you know like that
the movie opens with them stealing
jumping on a train and stealing coal and
selling it for a couple bags of milk
like the poverty in India is pretty
severe but should be clear he doesn't go
in a game show at the end and there's no
dent dance number that breaks out but so
he gets separated from his brother he
his brothers like just wait here at this
train station I gotta go work I'll be
back the kid five gets up doesn't work
wonders on the train the train leaves
and goes like 1600 kilometers away and
he's separated he's now in Calcutta he's
separated from his family and this is
you know it isn't like the way we grew
up or your kids grow your kids know your
address your phone number he's just like
I'm from this town and he's
mispronouncing it cuz he's five and he's
not there's now the great education
there you know so it's like and now
you're he's just lost so he gets adopted
from
an Australian family which is played by
nicole kidman she doesn't she doesn't
fantastic job in it and I'm going to
bring up the guy who plays her husband
to he's an Australian actor that does a
pretty good job as well Rooney Mara
plays his girlfriend so so anyway he he
David Wenham plays his dad so he
separated from his family and then
eventually gets adopted by this
Australian couple and then the there's
so then he's and Dev Patel isn't then an
adult who's like I have no identity I'm
Australian but I'm in like you know so
so that's what the story is and then his
search to find to go back home and find
his parents I cried throughout most of
this movie this movie is stunning and
the own there's like this is me totally
nit nit nit picking because I've watched
way too many movies it's a little slow
in the second act [ __ ] pics right back
up the first act is is a very graphic
depiction of what life in India is like
I'll give you just a little quick india
so in America poverty is if you make
whatever the number is 14 15 granny or
if you make less than that so if you
have a job and you make less than that
that's the poverty line in India it's
you don't have food drinkable water
that's the poverty line in India and
where to live and nowhere to live 300
million people live that way that's the
population of the United States of
America so you see this they shot this
it's like I mean they must have shot
this in Calcutta because it's like it's
it's hard to watch and eighty thousand
kids go missing every year in India how
are you Rin because it's when that kind
of poverty there's no way to track right
anyone how do you there's no nothing
like what if the entire population of
America was living at that level of
poverty
you wouldn't how do we they don't have
access to the internet or a social
security number there's no IDs it's like
it's insane so um and I'm sorry this
little kid who plays young replace day
patel's as a boy he should have got an
Oscar nomination he's as good as like
the kid in room the kid from beasts of
no nation like he's four thousand boys
audition deploy yeah Wow it was
unbelievable and this is the first time
director Gareth Davis it's his first
feature film so how and I gotta say it
should give someone with a home run it's
the best picture I'm looking at the list
the rival fences hacksaw Ridge hell or
high water hidden figures lala land lion
manchester-by-the-sea moonlight it's
lion tell you right now it's lion I
haven't seen manchester-by-the-sea your
moonlight but hell or high water is very
good but nothing else comes close to
this and not nothing in my opinion it's
that solid of a movie and the director
did amazing things with the shot
composition in the sound design using
sound design to help tell the story was
so not this isn't done enough so there's
a scene where the kid wakes up on the
train and is like where am I and he
Tunes out all of the sound so that you
feel the kids scared alone from the view
of a five-year-old boy of like this
daunting alone and just solitude and
item where's my brother and he keeps
screaming his brother's name just
gut-wrenching he doesn't with the sound
and then a little sound picks up and
then a little sound picks up and then
he's in Calcutta and then the mass sound
of this giant city with this crazy train
like and these little things happen all
the time then when Deb Patel is like is
so he grows up his Nicole Kidman and
they raise him in Tasmania which is an
island in Australia her in Keith Urban
reason
they liked it so I didn't move that
you're like well yeah oh we were making
a joke okay I'm really into then you're
doing a bit okay okay let me shift gears
of yes and so they're in Tasmania so
then he gets this goes to the on going
to school up in Melbourne so he goes up
to Melbourne and that's where he's like
they're all hits where he meets Rooney
Mara and they hang out with kids from
class and there's some kids who are grew
up in India and they're like where are
you from in India he's like I don't know
and they're just like until like these
memories get triggered and he keeps
having Australian accent yeah and he
worked really hard on it he's be
prepared for eight months to get this
Australian accent and just he stays in
aussie so he sounds like an Aussie and
it's like it was really it was a really
fantastic story and like I've known some
people like I had a friend was in
Australia and she was adopted from korea
and she went back to Korea to find her
family and like I know some people that
were adopted under those circumstances
and what it meant to them and how it how
conflicted they were and it's just it's
just a Fanta and it's a true story I
mean and there's just like you know and
it's it's gut-wrenching and also
beautiful in the same thing and all the
supporting casts are great you know um
you know the last three movies we talked
about where true story I know that's
Oscar bait it's real big Oscar bait but
this one is I mean it happened in you
know 1986 is when he was five year old
but he starts searching for his parents
in like 2008-2009 so it's it's not a
period piece really but it was really
it's it's not going to say it's
fantastic it's the best movie that I've
lenders to see you do you know feelin
being real upset you're going to cry a
lot unless you get inside hi dad
throughout hidden figures yeah what did
you think of that movie i liked it i
mean I in comparison to
you're talking about hidden figures i
was really engaged about the whole thing
i thought it was a really interesting
story pretty broad the way was done
pretty clean pretty stylized like
everyone's outfits were perfect and
their hair was perfect and the
everything looked perfectly composed
studio polish studio polish thank you
movie person I know those things that I
just took three sentences is described
but every time it was you know the
colored line for this or I started
crying and I felt ashamed and
uncomfortable and those that's powerful
that you know that to see that story I
mean it's not like Jackie at all but how
I was saying the hope for jackie was
like oh tell me tell me from this
perspective and hidden figures had that
where you're like whoa I knew this
period of time but I did not know that
and that that does awesome so yeah that
you know the story of them along with
watching the space race told him that
way and i took my eight-year-old son and
that was really exact exciting you know
just because i would you like it yeah he
was engaged throughout the whole thing
but uh you know little disconnects like
there's a part where she has to run
three quarters of a mile to go to the
bathroom and comes back and he you know
kevin costner's finally like where are
you going why are you not here when I
need and and my son was like where's she
going I'm like lychee and she's been
going to the bathroom he's like Oh sir
they're things like that were of you
know just lean over and say so you know
Russia's did that before he's like okay
I got it and then certain things like it
was done pretty clever with the ship
going around they showed it but they
didn't really show her I was a bit savvy
and then my son was like oh wait what
it's actually orbiting and I'm gonna
said yes oh okay but that was cool to
have him there for an really moving
story and hard to watch but inspire
yeah I i liked hidden figures as well
not hard to watch it was enjoyable it
was hard to watch in terms of the
reality the reality of it yeah I yeah
the one thing I and I talked about last
week was this sometimes when there's the
little to studio polish I almost like
that almost took me out of it a time
though they have great performances in
it and I did like it but sometimes this
I just felt like is this really where's
this the studio polished version
interesting you know almost it's almost
like a comforting a blanket of like look
we're going to hit all these notes of
reality but it's not going to be too
rough right for you yeah L is going to
be a nice blanket to carry this around
it's not going to the bottom is not
going to drop off right where Lion the
bottom drops off like it's it's this as
poverty in India this is these your kids
living on the street every day yeah
right now today and this is what they're
having to go through the first act is
the kid trying to survive and it's
brutal it's not and you're like and the
way they shoot it you can tell to me at
least it looked like they just set up
some cameras yeah and now in the
distance and people just I mean for as
much as I enjoyed hidden figures you
know like well her speech is coming or
she came off right you know she
something's going to happen the big
things are going to get their
comeuppance like that they have to that
scene is the one where I was like I have
no doubt I talked about it on the show I
have no doubt she had to walk three
quarters of a mile to go to the colored
restaurant I have no doubt but did she
did it happen that way where she gave a
big speech and Kevin right right right i
don't like did it really happen that
right if it did great i'm all for it but
did see this feels like Hollywood yeah
you're giving me the story the big
version you know what I mean like the
polished version versus did Kevin
Costner say well deal with it in real
life did his character go island walk
hot faster or did he say oh we're
switching the bathrooms and it was it
was fixed in a minute versus the big
speedy that's one thing I did like about
moonlight I know you guys talked about
that before but just
I had a friend of mine she's really
needy baldacci see below yeah she said
that moonlight now it was pretty slow
and it's such a discounting or just it
isn't like slow you mean because it paid
attention to the subtly of the human
heart that's what i call that pretty
beautiful and pretty groundbreaking
speed it up sensitive um I got business
that need to buy other biz matters right
I got a crush my calendar bulbs that it
took its time in that sense which may be
you know was ultimately not a good thing
about it but there were so many moments
and that that you're like oh this hurts
like he's just sitting there in it so I
know you haven't seen lion but of this
Best Picture list thus far of the ones
you have you're selling me online i
think i'm going to have a hard time
watching it but it sounds like it's got
all the yeah but I'm just like of the
ones you have seen what do you what
would you think so far i mean i don't
know i really liked hidden figures i
enjoyed it is it best picture probably
not I guess holly was over being mad at
Mel Gibson back arrival I really dug I
don't know if it's best picture but I
rival I thought was really intelligent
and it wasn't insulting and that the use
of suspense and the use of the aliens it
wasn't um yes it was really well done it
was engaging a it was a bit more
cerebral yeah yeah I'm really perplexed
that Mel Gibson is on this list I
thought hacks are rigids decent he did a
lot with a low budget director too yeah
that's perplexing tau there's a lot of
other directors out there and also like
the guy that directed lion like your
attitude is basically like he should be
done like yeah yeah I don't wanna I
don't want to go you know one thing for
the pod it's tough for a first-time
director to get phenomenon
nation through which one are you
hollering especially against an
anti-semite yeah that's two strikes
against the heartwarming story that puts
up a website to help kids in India at
the end of the movie while you're yeah
got it um a best picture you got
something yeah it is it is endep Patel
got Anna got a supporting actor for it
all right well let's talk about our
sponsor and then we'll get into the
Academy Awards boom we want to talk
about this is a online web series called
guardian pigeon by avin yap and this is
a fun series about dueling pigeon
conventions and 22 friends that were no
longer friends and they become bitter
rivals now one of the things i will give
a suggestion that i would like to see
for guardian pigeons is that they do
some behind-the-scenes stuff with like
the crew was a guest but i'd like to see
one with the Creator avenue app and have
him actually describe what attracted in
with the story why i wanted to tell the
story and how we kind of put it together
i'll be really interested in seeing that
behind the scene but it's a it's a
really fun webseries there's only like 6
5 episode 5 episodes you're eating my
view 7 minutes each you know it's like a
total of about 30 minutes it's a great i
mean it's a cool thing and it's
something to check out like as we've
talked about we like supporting into pay
artists we like supporting and really do
it yourselfers it's exactly what you're
watching you're watching young talent
like filmmakers even crew actors cut
their teeth that's really what you're
watching it's you know what it's it's
it's a great it's a great proving ground
so we just talked about you know lion is
an Australian production dead patel and
nicole kidman are famous but it's a lot
of other lesser-known people and i'm
sure they all started you know
everyone's starting doing stuff like
this that's why you should support it
because some of these people & Guardian
pigeons might pop out of this and you
might be the real where and it's a great
thing that's why if you're a young
filmmaker running around with a camera
and shooting web series you should
absolutely be doing that it's the best
school you could go to because you get
into
see your ass is the best teacher it's
about future and it's about unless you
get instant value and the other thing
too i like about when you're talking
about line like nicole kidman you know
she doesn't have to work with a
first-time director no that's like it's
hard to support this material in that
director which is great and you know the
more that you know the more established
artists do that to lift up the newer
artists it's always great to see ya and
then the less will have to get
nominations of Mel Gibson I don't know I
hear sequel cool so this is like back in
the days after the war so check out
guarding pigeons it is on youtube by
avin yeah and I think you guys subscribe
to it and like it those things you can
do for free that'd help you out for web
series it's like a couple people were
tweeting like what was the name of that
one again yeah so a bunch of people
already subscribe which is great thanks
guys for also not only supporting us but
also other artists so when you learn a
little bit while we talk a little bit
about the Academy Award yeah talked
about the best pictures were there
anything on this list that really jumped
out at you as how did this make it or
I'm so glad this was sort of because
here's like like I look at hell or high
water which is an excellent film on yeah
it's the reason it didn't so it got Jeff
Bridges gets Best Supporting for hell or
high water and you know that's like
about it and I think chris pine and and
ben foster kind of got the rest that
movie kind of got shunned a little bit i
think it might have suffered from
getting a release date in the summer
versus they didn't do a big graduation
like grammar december but some of those
things you know viola davis and i said
it when i saw that does she deserves a
nomination she gets one which is great
she's a fantastic actress Octavia
Spencer gets one as well I will say our
rival surprised me a little bit on best
picture I mean I know you guys like the
movie more than I did but I didn't hate
it right now even like what Mary Lynn
had said you know I liked about a little
bit's best picture it just feels like it
was when you look at everything in
general
feels like it was a little weaker of an
Oscar year this year just overall
overall I think there isn't there isn't
like four or five movies and up like I
don't know how any of the right beat
this other one yeah it's just sort of
your all decent DG like Manchester
bouncy I did like manchester-by-the-sea
but I have to promise with it too I mean
it i could see being nominated but it
was you know it was slow and set up like
a play and there was a lot of really
kind of dead air and time and it did not
stick the landing for sure what did you
think of it and see oh but you know I
will that's one of those ones as parents
you have a certain amount of time at
night and I'm trying to get my husband
I'm like like oh just your at the end of
your day like you can't watch that right
now I know it's going to read that I'm
having kids and it's sad that I just
admitted that but it has an old feel
shame i I've been going through there's
certain movies especially on the list
especially in the documentary category
you got to be in the right sometimes
watching I'm sure a lot of people did
that the walking dead at a certain point
where like I want to end my evening like
this yeah really into it for a few
seasons is like i don't i don't know the
energy to watch this endless hacking
open a body yes I don't I thought I wind
down my day I started watching old 30
rock I'm going through the whole fear
and I that's how I end my day little 22
minutes I'm nihilistic enough to still
enjoy walking dead oh my gosh golly kid
really I dropped off at the Union just
lady went on board i dropped i'll be
like season 3 i'm like every episode of
it make it art know the world's over to
be in your box hang yourself thank you
so now if you look at actor in a leading
role okay Casey Affleck I thought did a
really good job I haven't seen hack hack
Sauvage Andrew Garfield does a decent
job III he doesn't he does a decent job
I just there's a there's another act I
mean like honestly I would put the kid
from lion in his by as what i would do
because the kid is powerful he's a
powerful young actor you know so well I
mean also to you got like Ryan Gosling
it was a good
Carmen's but it was a lighter
performance some of you yeah I don't
know that but that shouldn't a good
performance is a good performance just
because the movie tone is light doesn't
mean that i agree with when i say a
lighter performance i mean like there
was there wasn't a ton to it like like
it was like it wasn't for death yeah it
felt like I don't know I mean I see what
you're saying but also I feel like there
was Ryan Gosling was still kind of
playing Ryan Gosling in the van man i
really like lala land but i didn't feel
like like I feel like actor in a leading
role is a performance that blows you
away from start to finish where you see
something from an actor and performance
that you just like you you can't forget
like like the performance like Mark
Ruffalo and spotlight reciting like that
when you see like you're just riveted
and and it stays with you after the film
Lim Chee till I get away before I could
never bring out the shampoo at G oh yes
yes in 12 years a slave like it's my
father Michael you after you're out of
the movie theater you're like wow you
know you'd still it stays with like like
that now I'm not saying it can't be a
common to your light or fun but it's
like I feel like for a Best Performance
it stays with you a little more ya know
viggo mortensen for Captain Fantastic I
didn't love this film but he did a good
job in it which is interesting like we
were talking about the pattern here it's
like you see Captain Fantastic in any
other category now no so it feels like
we have a lot of planet s can you see it
on here yet identify the other game yeah
so we have a lot of just kind of
compartmental heist movies where this
movie did this great but not this then
really did this great but not this well
yeah I mean Jackie means you know a lot
of them I think yeah yeah alright we
were going to do a whole episode I do
the ones i do want to mention though is
the animated film because this i find is
actually a really strong Category kubona
two strings amazing i hope it winds
mawana was really good too jokey was
really good my place is zucchini i
haven't seen and i've never heard
a bit until today I saw a trailer for it
ahead of lion into foreign it's a French
film and it looks really powerful it's
about a kid who's like mother goes away
and you have to go to like an orphanage
or something and it's it's it's really
interesting what medium is is it like
yeah I think it looks almost like clay
measure the inclination yeah okay and
now the red turtle this is a I just
learned about this one as well a
co-production between Studio Ghibli and
another studio and it posed to be this
beautiful film that's like a non
dialogue and immediately looked Riyadh
cat out a way kind of moving oh and but
again it's these movies some of these
animated features are so hard to find
before Oscar season hmm so I'm hoping
they make some of these a little more
available so like red turtle in my life
is easy i'd like to see both of them
yeah but you know the other films are
all filed like there's no good dinosaur
in that list you know they're very fun
you see a lot of these animated movies
because of your son Marilyn oh do you
see a lot of anime movies in general
like yeah I I don't really enjoy very
much he just dropped your kid off and go
I tried you yes I just was going out I
was really excited when he got this good
of hidden fences with me yes nice ladies
time I figure no because the women's
March I was marching against animated
films as a mom they should be said to be
more loyal to the lameness of myself I'm
sorry like how I was going to pick my
Oscar winner just not even having seen
to something I'm like yeah I'm going for
a lion just based on what you well you
might be right gonna from what I
dartboard some shots let me see I like
it all right well let's get into
trailers yes and guys you like would you
ever you will do a whole Oscar preview
like the probably that'll drop the week
before the Oscars and we'll do a whole
thing back lets you get time tested in
here this yearly visit
so Logan I saw this love this trailer
off that way to see this movie it's like
what we're going to do with Wolverine oh
this okay I'm on board yeah yeah I can't
wait to see this movie and isn't it Hugh
Jackman's left turn his Wolverine but
you know you don't I don't like it you
hear that I like well it's like when
Stephen King writes his last book you
know Mikey Mikey's gonna come back yeah
he's not gonna be done with Logan even a
week old man Logan this Phil is all
sorts of story arc no ma'am how does he
play body on over and the kids kids are
going to grow up a little what others
time travelers it's comic books it could
be any little Wolverine goes to college
and he's got to come to here in blaine
how he looks older yeah and Power
Rangers now did you see this trailer
this trailer it's funny i'm watching it
with my kids and it's literally it's
like catnip for 8 year old boy its you
know teenagers getting super powers you
know getting costumes fighting monsters
and then getting bigger and fighting
giant monsters and all that you know
then you know like like these giant
mechs that they get in and fight in
those and you know dinosaur shaped
machines and all sorts of really really
stuff where you just see like the eight
year-old boy's eyes get larger and
larger although even my eleven-year-old
daughter was like you know how to live
looks okay i think i might go ahead
wanna see you take your son to an island
I will yeah I'll enjoy it will you like
it yeah I'll just do a bunch of drugs
yeah so here's evil gold pre-movie drugs
when you go to a kids film I just do a
little bit of acid just a hint good
another mystical sekolah it evens out
and then you hot for you spread the time
result is vulnerable respectable so I
will be seeing how we think for our
ranges for sure as I'm sure you will now
have fun I'm very thankful that my kids
have started to slowly forget about
monster truck so I may not have to see
that one which is good here
the hook yeah my kid does want to see
the Batman like a movie really yeah yeah
why he's just not a no he doesn't always
want to get a call okay it looks like I
mean Batman and Legos yes I'm gonna be
that again it's like it's a small boy
like yes you know just died too just
tell me just say Lego and Batman
together there there he sold it yeah
take a poster yep you have a movie
hahaha so okay coming out on DVD and
blu-ray inferno yes I know you're
excited to see the wild Howard DaVinci
Code trillion I wonder what happens I
actually read the book to that's how
much of a masochist I was on that one I
am so excited to watch this on a plane
this is you get me through a flight and
it's going to be fantastic it's going to
be just the perfect amount as you engage
to get it will be on a plane for sure
sure and you'll go out and sleep on and
off yes you can wake up all and they
catch the demon guys all right I the old
scrolls they figured it out all right
and the light between the oceans is the
next movie and this is the Michael
Fassbender lighthouse they've been
pushing this release date back at times
it makes me scared it's like it's
already on DVD I'm lying wait when did
it come out or remember didn't get moved
or something weird was happening with
this movie and with where you know that
is a big sweeping romantic yeah and then
well it like he comes back from World
War one alright lighthouse and then a
baby shows up on the ground basis i'm
going to go back to the mainland
someone's missing a baby what are they
gonna do that happen to that you know
what the DVD that's what is amazing
hello there's another couple movies I'm
not ashamed and this is a looks like a
very I won't say he's a happy movie it's
it's based on a true story of someone
that was killed in the Columbine
massacre they went through all of her
kind of like notes and researched her
and basically made a movie about her so
it's going to talk about being crying
through a fair amount of this film it's
called I'm not ashamed and next one is
the handmaiden the
I believe a thriller period thriller and
I think it's Korean i believe food so
check that out and the monster which is
a low-budget horror movie about a mother
and daughter who don't get along but get
stranded on the road and chased by a
monster sweet so that sounds like that
would help with my oh yeah maybe it
doesn't mean that's the problem maybe
the moms like Oh Rosie to the mom wait
to see what happens you could twist so
and the side spotlight you have to read
Neal review of XXX the return of xander
cage yeah he's back yeah oh yeah the
return the return xander cage so glad to
Xander 2kg oh does literally these
they've now made these XXX movies more
like purity of course some literally
made a fast and furious movie you know
you know with just him in a different
coat no it's not even that he just has
tattoos I think right the same tank top
and the same yeah we're talking about
they probably shot him at the same time
yes so premiering this week is gold this
is the Matthew McConaughey I keep seeing
trailers for this and I'm curious this
could go either way was just trying to
be a Nostrum movie and it didn't hold so
they made it gave it this January
release I don't know it looks like it
should be interesting it's him all crazy
outfit looking ugly like accents and
beards and haircuts or what everybody
doing he buys gold so he's physical I'm
always finds a gold mine yeah
you know everybody after them they all
want a piece in the 80s it's based on
the true story so I don't know and the
next movies resident evil the final
chapter you know of course we'll see but
i I've played these games by the guilty
pleasure on these movies i will be going
to see this movie i have my umbrella
corporation umbrella if it's raining so
i will be going to see this Oh nerd nerd
nerd nerd and their nerd and then I want
to read this fan feedback real quick
margarine galaxy movies so we posted
Star Wars the last Jedi is in theaters
december twenty seventh and we posted
that and kurt Armbruster posted
greetings jedi starfighter you have been
recruited by the resistance to defend
the frontier against the first order of
the kylo Ren Armada that's the first
Starfighter mashup damage your kwaliteit
I like that that was very funny very
funny nice and airy references I like
the Last Starfighter all right dogs
purpose see the trailer you call me then
you see the how they shot it they're
torturing these dogs and you're like
pushing them in the water which dogs
hate it sounds awful like I don't want
to see this movie well this is bad no
one should see that there has been a lot
of pushback on that where the TMZ
falsely edited the video and there's a
lot of life responses where all the you
know the handlers onset is like that's
not what happened and then they go into
this long explanation although the
producer Kevin Flynn said yeah there was
some stuff happening on the set that you
know I wasn't happy with and Wade Oh
kept up and did that that you haven't
boat so here here's the thing here's the
we're never going to know exactly what
happened you've got a tape that was
possibly doctored you've got all these
people coming out against the movie
you've got also the people saying well
no the movies about animal rescue and
it's all the stuff so clearly something
happened to see well if right not happy
i said yeah yes is yes right will be
like that where if they if the producer
said keep this some stuff happened that
he did the eyes that's kind of and
there's some footage that's sort of like
yeah there's
sing me something over there now whether
it was doctored to make it much more
horrible than it actually was who knows
but it's also the kind of thing too and
all of it is true yes yeah it was
doctored and there were some it can be
either or exactly yeah i'm most likely
it was both so and my kind of abusing a
dog doesn't make it okay right exactly
exactly if videos made it worse but we
just kind of did it oh yeah oh no that
you know there's a there's all this walk
back in and like rationalization of like
we picked this dog because it loved
water and it didn't like where it was
jumping in and that's when we moved to
fact that's really what you're saying
I'm like oh my god and but here's the
thing Hollywood has been using animals
for many many years and there's all
these safeguards in place they're
supposed to be and you know if I want to
viewing this all the time for this to
happen you know this someone really
[ __ ] drop the ball for this to even
this never should happen with all the
safeguards in place on set never should
happen even if it was not as bad as the
video portrayed right and also clearly
something with them because the studio
pulled the movie for like a week yeah so
there was there was you know whether
smoke there's fire something happened
for sure now the movie is out this week
I don't expect big things from the box
office photos so an IMDB people are
weighing into all over the movie like
give it a chance still believe pita and
another thing the video was horrifying I
can't support this move it's like all
over the place to the point where
apparently IMDb was also starting to
pull reviews that weren't reviewing the
movie they were just talking about how
horrible the video was so judge for
yourself Oh or don't go out or the ass
vote with your dollars yes it's very
easy to not go to this movie oh all
right last movie kung foo yoga and
through yoga man is the things I liked
it and Jackie Chan to conclude yoga if
you watch the trailer for this film is
literally you have no idea what's going
on in this movie it's like it silly I'm
foo it's also there's they go to India
so that's where the yoga comes from but
also they
do this weird thing where they're
subtitled but a lot of it is in English
but their accents are so bad you feel
they don't know English they're just
being forced to say the words even
though they don't understand what it is
what they're saying and then some of it
isn't an Englishman that they fit i
guess the subtitle is dis cannot just
put it through the whole thing even a a
lot of its in English forget dog's
purpose about country BBQ yoga we're in
ya know yoga was harmed in the making ok
good let me call real downward dogs yeah
they were I tied it on guys I took both
of those we were talking about well
that's our show ladies and gentlemen no
yoga but thanks for having me i missed
you guys oh yeah i don't see you where
can people find you were on the internet
shows you're doing what do you got going
on i'm gonna be doing at midnight soon
and I did that cut the comedy jam have
you heard about that it's comedians
telling stories and then sing in a rock
song it's going to be crazy my comedy
central yeah we creep by radiohead
spoiler pause for thought and the
certain people doing some create and
some crazy guess that's a new show all
the time then locally in los angeles
superior comedy club near you and
there's a los angeles podcast festival
yes later in the year you guys totally
at 11 or 12 but night would you like to
I want to do as many podcasts in a row
where can people find you on like and
they talk oh at mary lynn rajskub on
twitter night right yeah talk about
everything let's do it follow her guy
what do you got coming up with other any
other shows or anything coming up I had
a show on amazon that that they kept us
waiting for a year for the pickup picked
up 45 and then they told us we're not
going to do it oh that's fun yeah so
that's happening I'm available alright
guys well that's our show may give you
guys a couple headshots yeah that's
where we're hiring there's room in the
garage for one more yeah we're gonna
build you is poured out of shirts um
guys the earbuds documentary the DVD is
done it's for sale autographed copies
from Chris and myself there's a whole
spot in there to get autographs from
other people to go
for gifts buy them for yourself comedy
film nurse calm of course it's available
digitally as well as well so that's our
show thank you Mary Lynn Rajskub thank
you I'm Graham Elwood and I'm Chris
Mancini has always remember han shot
first